I have 13 portfolio companies and I just
doubled one of them in 60 days by
solving five key problems and what I'm
going to do is show you the data of what
it was before why it was wrong what we
fixed and what happened after enjoy
three young Founders who are all sad
because they were not making the amount
of money that they wanted to make so
before I show you the data let me
explain what each of these terms
actually mean so show rate is the
percentage of people who have an
appointment who show up for their
appointment so in any business if you
deal with people you will have sessions
or appointments you have a time slot
that someone says they're going to show
up right if it's a sales consult then
they are a prospect and they're going to
show up to get sold so if I have 100
people who have an appointment and 70
show up that would be a 70% show rate
the second one here is offer rate which
we forgot to put in the rate so let me
just put that in for you there you go
offer rate which is the percentage of
people that we actually make an offer to
you might be like well why would I not
offer everybody well not everyone's
qualified and so for example if I work
with only gym owners and somebody comes
on it's like Oh I'm a personal trainer
well you shouldn't be here we had all
these other things that said don't be
here but you still came why are you here
that means that you don't offer them
anything and that's it now if 100% of
people who showed up show R you were
able to offer to then that means that
your offer rate would be 100% And that
is an indicator of the quality of the
lead flow that you have the third is
close rate this depends on how you can
track this all right so you can either
do it based on percentage of people who
show or you can do it on percentage of
people who are offered what I normally
do is I'll just track both I'm going to
guess that this one is off of offer rate
because it's what we have here it's good
to have both stats here because let's
say a Salesman wants to artificially
increase his close rate well then he
will just say well I'm not going to
offer anyone unless I know they're going
to say yes and so then their close
rate's high and then they'll show that
there's really low quality score but if
that salesman this is why having team
stats is so important and individually
is because if the team is all saying
that their offer rate 70 and one guy
saying is off rates 30 but he has 100%
close rate and they all have 30% close
rates we know where the data went and
this is why having high quality data
allows you to see what the problems are
if I didn't have this percentage then I
wouldn't know it's because we have low
quality leads or because my salesman
suck this data allow allows me to
identify the problem and then fix it so
the fourth set here is percentage of
cash collected up front meaning if we're
selling $1,000 widgets and the average
cash we collect today is $500 because
people do payment plans then we would
know our cash collected percentage would
be 50% if I have a low close rate at
high cash collected percentage that
would tell me a different story than a
really high close rate and really low
cash collected percentage I'd be like oh
so they're just getting anyone to say
yes and taking $10 down if they can
versus somebody saying we have a hard
line and so it's really trying to find
the mag between these two and saying how
can I get as many people to says and get
as much cash collected up front the
final one here is just unit sold and
this is really just the output of these
four if we multiple these things
together how many do we end up closing
and that's the result so beforehand damn
we had a 49% show rate so let's say we
have 100 appointments now we have 49 who
actually show up for their appointment
and then of the 49 we're able to offer
83% of them beforehand so 80% of that is
40 40 people now are getting offered out
of our original 100 appointments of the
people who get offered 27% of them which
is 10 people roughly are actually buying
in that closing percentage and then our
cash collected from those 10 people is
we're getting a little less than half of
the cash that we closed down now I gave
you 100 as a number but the actual
number of units sold for this business
in the prior month was 56 units all
right so this is current state if you
don't know these numbers in your
business you should so that you can
improve them let's say I invested in
your business today the first thing we
want to do is get the data so that we
can see what Baseline is so we can see
where the discrepancies are and where we
think the biggest opportunities for
improvement are and you're going to have
to wait till the end of the video for me
to show you what happened after so let's
start with problem number one or
opportunity for improvement number one
we had a low show rate as in based on
our benchmarks of 70% for any kind of
appointment type business we think that
we should have at least 70 there Allen
which is a company that I had all we did
was show rates we were doing 4,000
appointments a day we experimented we
had a machine learning team to think
like what was the number of
communications that we had to have with
a prospect what was the delay between
responses that got the most people what
were the total number of exchanges how
far apart were the exchanges there is
lots of data that we were able to
collect so their number was 49% of
appointments were showing up what we
wanted them to be at was 70% this is our
Benchmark where we'd say okay this isn't
a problem anymore now do we want to
improve things absolutely but where are
we going to allocate our effort at the
constraint this was a constraint now to
give context here this Delta is a 40%
difference 40% is a lot think about the
S&P 500 they're like we trying to grow
9% a year it's like boom I unlock that I
get 40% growth I don't have to do
anything else for like 4 years in the
S&P big wins that's what we look for
lots of things can affect show rate by
the way the number one one that affects
sh is number of total time sits you've
available take that to the bank but one
of the other ones is the targeting and
the offer itself so targeting is who's
actually seeing this promotion if I'm
targeting teeny boers for example I
might get people to schedule but then
realize that they're not here for a
laser hair removal appointment so the
targeting there would be off and so that
would affect our show rate and that has
nothing to do with our lead nurture
sequence or our salesman or anything
like that it's just the wrong people
were seeing it so that was issue number
one for context for us just imagine
that's underneath it was 25 to 35 year
olds who were gainfully employed and
love their job and this when we came in
to look at it was actually targeting 18
to 24 year olds the reason that this was
far off for us is that the ad objective
now I'm going to get a little bit
tactical with you ad acis.com at holdco
we have media buyers we have Pros who do
this for a living and so when they
zoomed in on how their media buyer was
optimized the traffic they were
optimizing against what a lot of people
would initially think they should do
which is optimizing for the lowest cost
leads and the lowest cost appointments
what we had to do we switch to optimize
around cost per sale if we can optimize
around who we actually sell to we will
shift where the sales come from and just
to give you how big of a problem this
was they had to cancel 75% of their
appointments before the 49% show rate
the sales guys are spending most of
their time just looking at their
appointment looking up the person
cancelling to get their 49% show rate
and that's about the closest thing to
literally burning money so the second
big problem was multitasking and this
really goes for any role but especially
like sales-driven roles they had a
setting team and a closing team and the
Setters were both trying to call leads
to get appointments and then also
nurturing and doing the followup to
remind them of the appointment and as
similar as that may sound in your mind
it's two completely different activities
you're banging phones calling people up
you're in that flow and then you're like
oh wait Sarah has an appointment today
let me go mind Sarah do Sarah going to
shup it and then you're like wait I'm
calling and then you start like and it's
you go back and forth right so they had
three big issues number one is that they
weren't double dialing right which is
one of the most common things that you
can do by the way if you're doing phone
calls because a lot of initial screens
will stop the first call but if you dial
twice you'll get through number two is
that the time to contact was too slow so
lead would come in and they would just
like sit there for 30 minutes 60 minutes
an hour 2 hours 3 hours right and they
weren't getting contacted it's like what
did this person do they're like oh I'd
like to find out more information
nothing and the third thing is that they
didn't have the right time to set
appointments and they weren't nurturing
correctly so we go same day next day I'm
just giving giving you some secrets and
they didn't have mning of nurture
meaning if you have an appointment today
and you booked this appointment 3 days
ago if I don't remind you that day that
you have an appointment the likely that
you show is lower and so these are the
problems that they have no double dial
slow speed to contact and they didn't
have any mning of nurture but wait
there's more the second problem they had
or opportunity for improvement was that
they had a low close rate and this is
based on our Benchmark I would normally
give you a kpi but it has so many
different variables in terms of what
percentage close rate is cuz if you're
sell in in person for example for a low
ticket thing you might be able to sell
80% plus of people walking the door on
the flip side if you're selling an
investment opportunity over the phone on
you know a first or second contact you
might sell 5% but for this particular
type of sale that they had which was a
two call close for like I would say a
mid-priced consumer service in my
opinion they should have been about 40%
so 40% is what I wanted them to be at
and then current was 27% so this is
where they were this where we wanted
them to be and again for context here
this is about a 50% % Improvement so
problem number one is that they had
service level Discovery if you're not
familiar with that terminology in a
sales script there's different kind of
phases that you go through in a
conversation and the opening part is
often a little bit of Rapport and then
right after that you get into Discovery
Discovery is where you're discovering
what the problems that the person is
going through you're trying to
understand why they are where they are
why they're on the phone with you why
they decided to take time out of their
day why this problem is important to
them what they've tried in the past etc
etc right this is the Discovery this
gives you all the ammunition that you're
going to use at the end of the sale to
close it so the way that they were doing
was simply saying how much money do you
want to make just asking the one
question which is the big obvious
question it's surface level but the big
thing that you always want to ask when
you're selling is intention why do they
want this like what changes as a result
of this how will your life look
different what can you not do now that
you would be able to do as a result of
this change who else in that in your
life would that affect why does that
matter to you right and so these are all
why questions and it's to to dig up
their intentions because if you can
understand why someone's there it's much
easier to get them to agree to getting
them there right but if you don't know
that someone's trying to let's say
replace their income versus quit their
job versus just have side hustle money
those are very different intentions if I
want to talk to side hustle money I'm
probably not going to be like this is
going to take a ton of time on the flip
side if someone's like I hate my job I
just want to do something that's not
this then I might talk about what the
day-to-day looks like in this scenario
and ask them if that sounds better to
them so if you think about sales
process what they were doing is they
were asking questions that were here
surfice level but this is where all the
meat is and that's where all the money
is is the questions that are below the
surface is understanding why someone's
even doing this to begin with look at
that Iceberg killer Iceberg and so the
second issue is that they had a lot of
objections coming up on the call I'll
say objections but I also mean obstacles
for those of you who are sales sales
senses objections happen after you talk
about the number obstacles happen before
you talk about the number if you come on
the phone and I say hey why are you here
and you're like I just want to find out
more information that's actually an obst
obstacle like you already have to
confront that cuz like no you're not
hopping on phone calls all trying to
find information what problem you trying
to solve and then they're like well and
then you get into it right but if you
don't address that up front it'll blow
up on you in the close so objections and
obstacles is what they were encountering
a lot of and part of that is because
their Discovery was wrong right they
were talking to service levels so then
lots of was blowing up on them in
the close common objections that happen
after you present price is uh this is
too much I need to think about it I have
to talk to my spouse I'm not sure if
this is for me I'd like to get more data
can you send me a brochure like these
are all just to make believe things that
people will say in order to not buy from
you interestingly a lot of times if you
stay in the surface level they'll even
give you what we call Smoke screens but
basically like they'll just come up with
uh a reason that they're not going to do
it and it's not even the reason they
just throw a smoke bomb up and they're
like I don't like English you know walk
away right has nothing to do with it
they just want to get off the phone so
those are the two issues that we had on
the sales and that was getting us to
this 27% close rate and what this looks
like is lots of argumentation and like
hard closing and it's because the sales
n positioned properly and they were
basically talking at people and not
listening if the salesperson is talking
more than the prospect in your sales
like these are likely issues that are
coming up I'm going to give you two
examples real quick to show you how
important delivery of a message is so if
I say I have to think about it and I say
oh like what are your main concerns or
what are the main like what are the main
variables that you're considering you're
not thinking wow this guy's a douchebag
I sound like I just genuinely want to
know I call it childlike curiosity I
always cue it by tilting my head I'm
like huh what are the main things and I
would increase my voice at the end there
an improperly trained salesp person
might be like well what are the main
concerns you have and all of a sudden
that sounds like a very different thing
so they're saying the script but they're
not but the prospect isn't hearing the
same message and these are little
details that actually can make a huge
difference in ultimately how you close
there's a lot of things in tone but I'll
just say one is how you raise or lower
your voice and the second is where you
choose to emphasize if I say I didn't
say he hit his wife if I say like that I
have neutral Tone If I say I didn't say
he hit his wife then it's like I'm not
saying that I didn't say he hit his wife
is now saying that like those weren't my
words I didn't say he hit his wife he's
the one to question I didn't say he hit
his wife means like he might have done
something else but he did something to
his wife I didn't say he hit his wife it
could have been somebody else's I didn't
say he hit his wife it might have been
his kid right and so it's the same
sentence but simply emphasizing
different parts of it communicate
different things and so the tone and
emphasis create a altogether package of
how we communicate and for them their
tonality was way off as a team because
they were missing the first 5 minutes of
disc discovering and setting the frame
properly and so I'll give you the last
set of problems opportunities for
improvement and then we'll dive into
what we did to solve them and what
happened sales problem three opportunity
for improvement people in orc structure
issues so issue number one is that CEO
was the sales manager and that was
because he was the best closer he had a
significantly higher close rate than the
rest of the team but he wasn't a very
good sales manager even though he was a
good Closer by the way that's one of the
main issues that a lot of sales teams
have they promote their best closer as a
sales manager and often times those are
two very different skills and we could
see this because the churn on their
sales team was through the roof just to
be clear like they were a group of young
Founders it's not uncommon it's actually
probably very common because usually
when you start a business learning how
to promote and sell the product is
usually the job of the founders like how
do I get people to want to buy the thing
and so they end up getting the most reps
early on and also understanding the
prospect better than just about anyone
and so one of the big things you guys
are in little mini sales last Su today
is that companies will over educate on
the product and under educate on the
prospect the person that you should be
educating your sales stuff on is who
we're talking to more than what we're
selling cuz for me if I know someone
deep in their core what their intentions
are I can tell them anything I know
someone inside and out and then someone
says sell this thing and I know nothing
about it I could probably get them to
buy on the flip side I know everything
about this thing and I don't know who
I'm talking to talking to a child a man
a woman old young different language and
so a lot of people talk like hey sell me
this pen when in reality what we want to
do is like talk to John the majority of
good sales train trainers who try to do
that gimmick what they want the person
to do is ask them a question it actually
has nothing to do with the pen and so if
they say sell me this pen what you do is
you take the pen and you put it in your
pocket and you say how's it going what
brought you in today right cuz I got to
go from where they're at to wanting a
pen I'm not going to just be like hey
buy this pen give me money like it
doesn't work that way but bad salesman
do so the second issue was the setting
team expectations one of the benefits of
working with someone who has more
experience is that we know what the
Benchmark should be and so a lot of
times we can reset someone's minimum
standard and they're like well they're
setting two a day and we're like they
should all be minimum setting three and
that sounds tiny but again two to three
is a 50% increase in sets and that's
across a whole team so that means a lot
of productivity but if you set the bar
low people will just naturally shrink
down to that level all right so you
understand the problems and here is the
data this is before they had a low show
rate issue they had low close rate and
multiple issues around that and they had
people and organizational issues so I
want you to pause real quick in the
video in the comments to be like what
would you do how would you attack these
issue if this was your business and then
I'll tell you what we
did now there's two elements of
solutions element one is what would you
do to attempt to solve the problem and
the second is which one do we do in what
order the third problem that was
actually the first thing we decided to
fix was that we hired a sales director
the reason for that was because the CEO
was overly involved he was micromanaging
he wasn't a good manager and he also
wasn't doing CEO stuff and so we had to
hire an experienced sales director who
in this instance had been a sales
trainer for a similar type of sale in a
consumer good this guy ended up being
exceptional in being able to implement
the rest of the changes that we outlined
so this was in terms of order of
importance I think if we hadn't done
this and had tried to do the rest of
them it would have fallen flat this is
like one of the most common errors that
business owners and Founders make is
that they see the what and not the who
or they focus on the how and not The Who
and if you have the same problem that
has recurred multiple quarters in a row
in the same Department underneath of the
same who it might not be a what issue it
might be a who issue one of the reasons
having experience is helpful is because
you know what it looks like when it's
right some of the biggest costs in the
business are hiring incorrectly you
waste the time trying to find them you
waste the time onboarding them and
trading them and then you waste the time
of all the time it takes you to figure
out that they're not the right fit and
all the loss growth that you would have
had to then start that process over
again that's tough but a lot of
businesses have to deal with that which
is why picking Personnel is so important
with this instance we looked at culture
fit which is like do we think that this
guy will fit in which we usually the
founders pick that part out like hey
does this guy fit in cool and then we're
going to hardcore drill on usually
experience and tactical knowledge and so
we have subject matter experts at holdco
media buying cro experts sales experts
Finance expert whatever and we will then
do tactical interviews we talked about
earlier you can know that someone is
good based on the quality and quantity
of the data that they collect I would
ask somebody what data do you plan on
collecting and how would you plan on
fixing those things based on how vague
they are and how high level they go in
terms of their Solutions it'll tell you
how nuan they can be in their thinking
and ultimately executing Solutions sales
director specifically in my experience
when I have guys who are like I just
want to build up people I want to give
these guys skills and they marry that
with like and these are the metrics that
I track to know X Y and Z that's a good
sales director the next thing we decided
to solve boom was fixing the ad
targeting and the reason we did the
sales director first was because we're
like well how do we know if anything
else is going to happen afterwards if we
fix this so what we ended up doing here
it turns out is that we also had another
Personnel issue the media buyer was
asleep at the wheel they were optimizing
around the wrong stuff they were trying
to split their attention and start their
own side hustle it was clear that they
were negligent they actually were doing
the right thing and then they stopped
doing the right thing and it was clear
that that type of behavior the founders
felt was not going to correct itself so
they let go of that person hired a new
person and boom fixed the ad targeting
problem we were back to 25 to 35y old
people who love their job what did we
fix next boom We reduced the sales team
what and we reset expectations for the
setting team what we looked at is sales
team utilization if we know that guys
can take 10 sales a day and they're
actually only taking four then we have
too many salese in this instance it
gives you an opportunity to cut the fast
for lack of better term and reward the
people who are actually doing their jobs
and closing well if you cut the lowest
percent of the team and you have
utilization like you have space you lose
the lowest closing percentage people and
you gain more closes just by Shifting
the closing rate overall of the team
when you make those changes in my
experience sales people get into a
rhythm if you don't take enough sales
calls you're too desperate to close the
deal and then you start being too hard
and not listening enough cuz it's about
you not them when sales people have more
and more consult they sell from the back
of their heel they're open-minded
they're asking questions they're feeling
good and they get in a rhythm the
setting team we both downsized and
increased expectations how did all these
sales increase by having fewer people we
had better people that's how and that
also helps recreate the culture of the
team so that we can have a new standard
set of high performers because there's
nothing that demotivates a high
performer like a low performer who's
still on the team and so we went from
two to four in terms of our expectation
per day for the team in terms of sets
sales fix numo qu
I'm messing all my columns up now just
going to have to deal with it we
promoted one Setter to lead nurture
specialist I was saying earlier that
they were multitasking right so they're
doing some setting and they're doing
some lead nurture and that gets really
hard for a team of six guys to split
those things we took one of the Setters
who was really good and made that person
the lead nurture specialist who
basically acted as the bridge for both
the setting team and the closing team to
basically coordinate and remind the
people of their appointments and we
equipped that lead nurture specialist
with one of our checklists for what that
role needs to do to get the most people
to show up and I'm not going to give you
all cuz a long check list I'll give you
two quick examples one of them is doing
a three-way intro once you have the set
appointment between the setter and the
closer and doing it via iPhone if you
can because now you have a known person
and an unknown person and a person that
Bridges the two they might know show on
Johnny over here but not on the guy that
they just spoke with and so the idea is
how can I bridge that Gap and kind of
make the association for them add some
trust the other thing is that the
closers morning of would remind them
with either a voice memo or a video text
personalized to them being like hey John
really excited for our part today I saw
your profile XYZ personalized to you I'm
really pumped for I think we might help
you out so that's just a couple of the
things that we have on that list that we
had them Implement and all do
consistently and sales team fix number
five boom is we optimize the sales
scripts I said earlier that the
discovery was to surface level so we
rescripted the discovery made sure we
were asking deeper more meaningful
questions and a part of that is also
bringing some of the objections to the
front it's much easier and this is the
this is the terminology that our team
uses which is killing zombies right it's
a lot easier to kill a zombie when it's
far away than when it's on top of you if
somebody's trying to bring up a zombie
in the cloth another way of saying it is
like you want to diffuse the bomb before
it goes off in the clothes in your face
so we solve the problem before we bring
it up now this is actually something
that we added to this part of the script
which is prior to the appointment we say
hey is there anyone else who' be
required to make a decision about this
thing if they say yes then you say cool
well let's push back the appointment
let's get that person on that way you
have all the decision makers present so
these are just little things but like
little 1% improvements over and over
over again is what yield these 50%
boosts and the third main change we did
was that we drilled the team on looping
and looping is just a sales terminology
for basically when you encounter an
objection handling the objection and
then asking again handle the objection
ask again right because a lot of salese
are afraid to ask if someone says no and
they don't want to ask again right and I
can tell you this is that the number of
sales you make is direct proportional to
how many times you ask there's ways to
do it wrong and there's ways to do it
right the idea is that you should be
able to resolve the concern right so if
someone says I need to think about it
and you say well what are your main
concerns and they say say well it seems
really complicated you say oh what part
specifically feels more complicated
they're like it's the whole Tech thing
and we're like oh we also have a vendor
that can actually fill that in I think
it's a couple bucks extra but like we
can just handle that for you does that
solve the problem and they're like oh
okay so you guys will you guys will just
hand that one part of it like yeah we
hand that part of it for you cool now
this is where the salesman says great
you want to move forward you have your
idea on you hey what card you want like
you can just make the ask right after
that and so then at that point you might
say ready to move forward then and they
might say this feels like a fast
decision it's like oh well what makes it
fast how long you been thinking about
this they're like well I mean I just met
you and you say well how long have you
wanted to solve this problem and then
they would say well I mean a long time
it's like well then doesn't sound like a
fast decision at all it sounds like
you've already made the decision a long
time ago that you wanted to change now
we're just acting on it so now do you
want to move forward right keep looping
and continuing to resolve the concern
ask again resolve the concern ask again
drum roll
please what happened in the real world
so let's go to the data all right so in
our first column we had 49% sure rates
after we implemented sales fix 2 fixing
the ad targeting sales Fix 4 promoted
one lead Setter to lead nurture
specialist and sales fix 3 reduce the
team size and reset expectations survey
says we had a 70% boost which is almost
exactly the kpi and that's because when
you do things that work they work so
that was a 40% Improvement in sales and
to be clear this was just over 2 months
all right so some of these Chang is
going to happen real quick if you know
what you're doing the second change we
have is our offer rate and so here's
what happened survey says
80% we actually offered just about the
same amount of people realistically what
they were doing is offering people who
weren't qualified cuz the sales team
wanted to eat and I get that like
there's a human component here they were
offering people were not qualified the
deal cuz they needed commissions right
which is what we were trying to fix with
the targeting close rates we went from
27% in 60 days later we were
at 41% so 1% above our Benchmark all
right this is a 50% Improvement in sales
so 40 and 50 Kazam next up we have
percentage of cash collected a really
good metric for knowing how strong the
sales team in is and this is especially
important for that early Discovery
portion and how good they are at looping
and closing because the deeper you get
the discovery the the more convicted the
buyer will be about the solution and the
more likely they are to pay UPF FR as a
measure of their conviction in the
solution the survey says we went from 47
to 82% so we almost doubled the amount
of cash that we were collecting UPF
front per sale in 60 days we had a 40%
Improvement and we had a 50% Improvement
and we had a almost doubling of cash
collected so if we almost doubled the
amount of sales that happened and we
almost doubled the cash up front
collected what did we do to the cash
flow of the business forx ah much more
enticing after we added all these four
changes together and we waited 60 days
what happened survey says we went from
56 to 93 sales a month and that was just
from a few of these fixes on one
particular part of the organization and
you might think after we made all these
changes that we're done we right off
into the sunset but wait there's more
there were even more problems in the
business on the product and customer
success side which we will get to in the
next video